das Feedback von meinem letzten
Video-Podcast ist ganz gut gewesen und
deswegen dachte ich mache ich einfach
mal eine zweite Folge wir schauen was
wird was wird und heute färbe ich mir
die Haare
ich werde mir in die Haare ja nicht mehr
weil ich was Neues ausprobiere sondern
weil ich einfach meine grauen Haare
überdecken möchte ich färbe sie alle
zwei Monate ungefähr also wenn ich dann
wieder Silber durch wenn was silbernes
durchscheint dann ist auf jeden Fall
wieder Zeit und passend zu diesem Thema
Haare färben habe ich gedacht mache ich
heute oder spreche ich heute über das
Thema gensi vs millennial und es ist so
ein Thema das ist mir schon lange auf
dem Herzen weil es mir vor einigen
eigentlich schon Jahren aufgefallen ist
als
tiktok und Genie und so ein bisschen
mehr Thema wurde und da ging es ganz
viel darum um emojis welche emojis
benutzen die Mädel erniels und welche
die sind und da habe ich schon das erste
Mal gemerkt dass es so ein ganz
komischer Ton im Internet ist ja
plötzlich herrscht also ich würde nicht
Mobbing sagen weil mobbing ist schon das
sind sehr harter Begriff gerade für die
Leute die Mobbing erlebt haben finde ich
nicht sollte man damit einfach so um
sich werfen aber
ja es fühlt sich halt schon so an als ob
man also so ein bisschen sich über eine
andere Generation lustig machen okay
aber richtig
aggressiv bzw so immer wieder darüber zu
sprechen dass mein Gott diesen emoji
kann man nicht mehr benutzen das ist so
eine
strikte und und aggressive Art irgendwie
also Trends ja okay man kann Trends
folgen oder man kann sich dagegen
entscheiden und Trends nicht folgen aber
etwas so auszuschließen und zu sagen ja
also du bist nicht cool wenn du diesen
emoji benutzt oder das schreibst oder
dieser Humor ist Grinch oh Gott ich darf
gar nicht anfangen über Grinch zu reden
denn dieses dieser Begriff Grinch wird
auch so das wird so unsicher geworden
und alles was irgendwie nicht
cool hip-jungfern Grinch ich weiß nicht
ich finde man sollte definitiv netter
miteinander umgehen und da habe ich mich
gefragt warum ist das eigentlich so wenn
ich jetzt an meine Jugend zurück denke
also da war klar da gab's so wir jung
Leute und das sind die Erwachsenen
älteren
aber es gab nicht so also man hat eher
zu den älteren aufgeschaut habe ich das
Gefühl und die älteren waren halt cool
weil die konnten sich halt schon Sachen
leisten oder konnten
keine Ahnung in Clubs in die haben
einfach das Leben gelebt so
und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl dass seit
wir uns alle auf der gleichen Plattform
befinden
dass es so wie so ein Schlachtfeld
geworden ist so einmal die Haare
abtrennen
und dann würde ich sagen gehen wir
einfach Milch rein wir tummeln uns jetzt
halt alle auf der gleichen Plattform
tiktok
und kriegen alle ungefähr die gleichen
Videos zu gespielt also ich glaube die
viele jüngere Leute Genesis kriegen viel
mit Tanzvideos und tanztrends
ausgespielt also ich sehe leider
niemanden auf meiner for you page tanzen
obwohl ich das eigentlich auch immer
ganz gut finde also ich habe aber glaube
ich zu wenig auf Leid gedrückt dass der
Algorithmus denkt ja
Vanessa will Teenager tanzen sehen aber
wir befinden uns halt alle auf dieser
Plattform
und was man dann in den Kommentaren
liest also ich finde es ja auch ganz
lustig wenn mich wenn ich dann mal so
ein Video sehe das sagen jensis
oder das ist typisch denn sie ist das
ist typisch Millenials Millennials in
ihrer zweiten Midlife Crisis aber das
ist dann eher so
neutral sie einfach lustig drüber machen
was ich aber nicht verstehe ist halt
dieses gegeneinander und ich muss aus
meiner Erfahrung sagen ich habe das
Gefühl dass es eher Genesis gegen
Millennials was was die so alles an uns
sehen was ich mittlerweile halt auch
echt das verunsichert mich auch total
wenn ich z.B dann sagen die dann siehst
so ja die millennialpause in der Story
wenn wenn jemanden eine Story macht und
dann erstmal diese kleine Pause davor
hat weil die halt auf Record drücken und
dann warten Sie kurz und dann fangen sie
an zu sprechen das würden ja denn sie
ist niemals machen oder wenn ich zum
Beispiel eine Story mache dann zoome ich
immer mal wieder an das Objekt dran weil
das man halt so gemacht hat und man das
einfach so drin hat und wenn dann meine
Nichte also die mobbt mich jetzt nicht
dafür aber wenn meine Nichte das sieht
oder wenn halt
wenn ich das mache dann
dann wird das schon mal kommentiert
dieses ranzoom dass man das einfach
nicht mehr macht so und da frage ich
mich wie weit können also ist das jetzt
halt dann nicht mehr im Trend und der
Trend ist es sich so zu verhalten
bedeutet das nicht aber auch dass das
ist so eine Blaupause gibt für das Leben
mittlerweile also ich finde es gibt ja
schon so eine Blaupause wenn man was für
Klamotten man trägt so also ohne dass
man glaube ich aktiv macht aber wenn
dann halt Schlaghosen in sind oder dann
sind die Skinny Jeans jetzt bei uns
Millennials waren es immer die Skinny
Jeans und dann sind die nicht mehr
und ich trag auch noch Skinny Jeans ab
und zu wenn es zum Outfits passt aber
dadurch dass es halt so so
out ist
ob jetzt bewusst oder unbewusst trage
ich halt auch nicht so oft
und dass das meine ich mit Blaupause
also das so eine Blaupause
auf Make-up auf Haare auf
trendige Urlaubsorte und ich habe das
Gefühl diese Blaupause wurde jetzt halt
auch auf sein Verhalten auf Social Media
übertragen bzw sein Verhalten allgemein
aber gerade was Social Media angeht so
und dann kommt da halt so was dazu was
wir emojis benutzt du wie zoomst du ran
was zeigst du in deinem Feed dann sehe
ich auch sonst da tiktok so so sieht ein
Genie Feed aus so sieht ein millennial
Feed aus und wenn man das einfach nur
neutral betrachten würde okay aber sorry
ich habe nie das Gefühl dass das neutral
ist sondern immer mit so einem Judy so
also die Millennials machen nur selfies
von sich ähm bei den Genesis siehst du
halt viel mehr realistische Bilder bzw
so
querky Fotos und und und irgendwie so
random random Zeug was sie dann
fotografieren und einfach posten und auf
dem Feed von einem sie sieht man dann
z.B kaum äh deren Gesicht und wenn dann
ist es so ganz blöde und also so und
okay dann ja dann ist das halt so wie
wir lernen jetzt machen das so ihr macht
so aber warum musste immer mit das da
ist immer dieser Unterton mit rein so
ja
guck mal was die Scheiße machen und ich
finde das für uns sichert mich
mittlerweile also gerade weil das
Internet oder Social Media so ein Raum
ist wo wir uns ja alle drauf befinden
und wenn man dann ja ständig sieht dass
sich über etwas lustig gemacht wird und
das so gezeigt wird also guck mal wie
peinlich ja na klar überlege ich mir
dann das nächste mal doppelt oh ist das
überhaupt noch cool wenn ich das und das
sage oder das sind das poste oder diesen
emoji benutze bei den emojis muss ich
sagen ich werde gerne so konfident wie
ein Puma Puma benutzen emojis ohne Ende
und ganz ehrlich wenn meine
Schwiegermutter mir ein eine Nachricht
mit ganz vielen emojis schickt
dann denke ich mir so ja you go-girl
pack die emojis rein 3000 verschiedene
die du da gefunden hast aber warum das
ist so das muss man doch nicht judgen
das ist halt das ist halt wie es ist und
können wir nicht und ich hatte das
Gefühl oder ist es nicht so dass man
eigentlich über gensie sagt dass die
jetzt so auf meine sind und das ganze
Vogue Ding und so mit mitbringen und
halt einfach Offenheit gegenüber allen
und und Toleranz ich dachte das wird in
dieser Generation so groß geschrieben
aber was dieses Thema angeht habe ich
das Gefühl nee da die sind so lange tot
solange du nicht diesen lachenden emoji
mit den Tränen in den Augen schreibst
dann ist bei den vorbei ich weiß nicht
wann das war aber vor einigen Monaten
habe ich das zu jemandem geschickt
glaube ich der mehr Genesis als
millennial
und die Person hat das sogar kommentiert
und hat gesagt so benutzt du den noch
den den kann man nicht also scheiße und
dann habe ich diesen emoji plötzlich mit
so anderen damit ist das jetzt uncool
wenn ich diesen emoji benutze wo ich mir
jetzt so denke mann warum muss man denn
alles so mag ich machen ich kann auch
hier meine emojis benutzen wie ich will
was ist also haben wir nicht andere
Probleme als emojis
ob die jetzt noch cool sind oder nicht
und sorry Jenny ich verstehe auch nicht
wenn man
wenn man Totenköpfe benutzt statt
lachsmileys ja lachst du dich jetzt tot
okay das ist aber
es gibt mir keinen guten weiB ich habe
dann keine gute Stimmung und ich habe
noch nie in Melle gehört der darüber
sich aufgeregt hat gesagt hat so warum
benutzen die totenkörper das ja super
weird ihr tanzt eure Tänze auf tiktok
und wir lassen euch alle machen wir
lassen euch alle machen
und es soll jetzt auf jeden Fall auch
nicht so klingen als ob alle Genesis
sind gemein und alle Millennials sind
die Opfer das meine ich ja gar nicht
aber
wenn man so den Grundton
der Generation auffangen möchte dann
kommt ein so rüber und warum ich
überhaupt darüber sprechen wollte über
dieses Thema ist weil es mich einerseits
halt schon länger beschäftigt aber ich
habe einen tiktok gesehen wo jemand
darüber gesprochen hat warum es
überhaupt also zu diesem zu diesem
auf Englisch gesagt aber zu dieser
Trennung
zu dieser Kluft zwischen den
Generationen gekommen ist
und der Grund hat mich wirklich
erschrocken also legendly anscheinend
ich habe hier keine ich bin hier ich
habe hier keine Quellen nichts
die Begriffe werden von der Wirtschaft
festgelegt also economy hat er gesagt
ich vermute mal dass es Wirtschaft jetzt
heißt
und
das macht für die Wirtschaft natürlich
Sinn weil sie müssen Gruppen von
Menschen irgendwie beschreiben dass sie
dann wenn Sie über diese Gruppe sprechen
wissen wen sie meinen denn ein gensie
hat ein anderes Kaufverhalten als ein
millennial und eine millennial hat ein
anderes Kaufverhalten als ein Puma oder
Jenny ich weiß nicht mehr wo ist Jenny
ich glaube zwischen
millennial und Boomer
und das ist dann natürlich für die
Wirtschaft super praktisch wenn sie dann
sagen ja die Genesis ne die sind so und
so und deswegen können wir das und das
besser an sie verkaufen weil das ist ja
das was also darum geht's ja im ganzen
Leben die etwas zu verkaufen das ist wo
sich eine Welt dreht und es funktioniert
super und wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt
dann ist es doch noch viel affiger dass
wir darauf reinfallen und uns
untereinander so trennen lassen in so
begriffen und
Eigenarten und der Mensch ist so und der
Mensch ist so und
ja
ich finde
man musste auf jeden Fall gegensteuern
und ich will mir auf jeden Fall auch
vornehmen dass ich keine Gedanken mehr
daran verschwende wie ich etwas schreibe
poste da gibt es dann auch das habe ich
dann auch auf dich mittlerweile sehe ich
alles auf tiktok ich glaube wenn ich
über Themen spreche dann ist es immer
nur weil ich auf tiktok was gesehen habe
was mir eigentlich grundsätzlich nicht
so schlimm ist ich finde tiktok bringt
mich auch viel zum Nachdenken über viele
Themen oft viel zu negativ also ich habe
ja in der letzten Folge darüber
gesprochen dass ich sehr negativ bin ich
habe mir mal mein tik tok-feed angeguckt
mal ein bisschen bewusster und mir ist
auf jeden Fall aufgefallen dass da
einiges an negatives verbreitet wird
weil die bereits ich sehe sind natürlich
immer
irgendwelche entsetzlichen Sachen die
passiert sind klar auch meinen lustigen
Katzenvideo aber ne wenn dann so mein
Freund hat mir Schluss gemacht weil das
sind das oder der hat so mit mir Schluss
gemacht und ähm der hat den angegriffen
und so ja und meine Themen sind
mittlerweile einfach nur noch Themen die
hier gefunden habe ja und da war auch
ein Thema über Instagram Story ich bin
hier gerade so ein bisschen hin und her
aber da war ein Thema über Instagram
Story wie man heutzutage denn jetzt
seine Instagram Stories macht und du
erkennst einen Millennium sofort daran
wenn ein Gifs in seine Stories packt
und dann habe ich mir das angeschaut und
dachte mir okay ja dann mache ich
natürlich keine Gifs mehr rein weil ich
will ja nicht uncool sein ich will ja
nicht hinterher sein die Leute sollen ja
denken ich bin hip
vielleicht wollte ich auch einfach nur
meine Kundschaft nicht verlieren möchte
ihr seid meine Kundschaft und ich möchte
mit allen connecten nee eigentlich
möchte ich nur noch Buma Content machen
weil ich glaube die Puma sind die die am
meisten Zeit haben um Content zu gucken
also die Rentner nicht die Boomer die
noch in Vollzeit arbeiten und Kinder zu
Hause haben die sind das eigentliche
ich finde das auch wirklich so
anstrengend da hinterher zu kommen wäre
was ist von wem wir alle Angst haben
sollten sind allerdings die iPads also
die Generation die jetzt nach den ginsis
kommt die wirklich mit iPads in ihrer
Hand groß geworden sind
dauerhaft und dauerhaft gefilmt werden
ich glaube das dann um die müssen wir
uns sehr gut kümmern ich bin eigentlich
mega froh ein millennial zu sein ich
liebe es
also ich finde wir sind in der besten
Zeit groß geworden weil wir beides in
unser frühen Kindheit erleben konnten
ich bin 1993 geboren da hatte noch
keiner in meiner Familie ein Handy da
gab es Internet ja es gab aber man hat
also keine Ahnung hat es benutzt ich
glaube der eine Nachbar meiner Freundin
hat's also der Vater meiner Nachbarin
hat benutzt und das war's und also
keiner war ja da also was sollte man mit
dem Internet und konnte mal was
recherchieren und dann gab es da so eine
ganz
freudige Seite wo ein paar Infos drauf
standen
so und als millennial ist man aber dann
so schön in diese in diesem Umschwung
auch groß geworden
dann gab es AOL dann kannst du über
diese AOL CDs die ich eine sehr
intensive Erinnerung habe irgendwie
ich glaube weil ich immer ich habe die
lagen immer überall gratis rum und ich
wollte die immer mitnehmen und habe sie
glaube ich auch immer mitgenommen weil
ich dachte dadurch kann man dann
Internet auf seinen Computer bekommen
Router und sowas anschließen muss und
deswegen habe ich sie mal mitgenommen
meine Eltern haben sie halt was sollen
sie damit das ist halt eine Arbeit
naja und dann kam Messenger ICQ und da
war ich so 14 und da habe ich alles so
schön nach und nach miterlebt und
schülervorzelt Facebook und dann kam
2012 glaube ich kam dann Instagram dann
hat man plötzlich so so coole Fotos
teilen können obwohl wir auch mal schon
Fotos geteilt haben auf Fotos
irgendwann mal gelöscht zum Glück habe
ich getan das war wirklich peinlich es
war so zur EMO Zeit hat man dann auch
Foto locker mal Bilder gepostet mit so
oder Titel ist eigentlich was Instagram
halt nur als Website photox hätte mal
sich durchsetzen können so und als
millennial finde ich was die geile Zeit
und dann hat man mitbekommen wie denn
das iPhone raus kam und dann hatten
schon die ersten Leute iPhone in der
Klasse und dann
hatte man irgendwann selber ein
Smartphone und natürlich kein iPhone
sondern irgendeins ich glaube ja dann
Samsung irgendwas nach meinem Sony
Ericsson Walkman und man weiß quasi noch
wie es ist cute SMS zu schreiben
und anzurufen und vorbei zu fahren bei
jemanden um zu gucken ob der da ist aber
man weiß auch wie toll das ist das
mittlerweile mit dem Handy eine alles
möglich ist auch wenn sie seine
negativen Seiten hat und ohne Dich
gibt's halt keinen Schatten ne
aber es ist es ist schön dass wir jetzt
ja so connected sind und alle ein
Smartphone in der Hand haben wir hatten
die beste Zeit erlebt wir haben MTV
Videos erlebt
im TV wie war sich darauf freuen im
Fernsehen anmachen und darauf warten
dass Viva Top 100 kommt und dann kommen
die ganze Zeit Musikvideos und man
konnte den Fernsehen laufen lassen und
dann lief Musik im Zimmer ich hatte nie
einen wie heißt das
und CD Player oder sowas doch ich hatte
glaube ich irgendwann CD Player mit
Radio das war auch hammer gab es noch
kein Spotify also was schlage ich vor
ich schlage vor dass wir uns darüber mal
Gedanken machen und das wir uns
einheitlich dazu entscheiden uns nicht
mehr mobben zu lassen ich zumindest ich
werde mir so Mühe geben ich bin richtig
im Wandel gerade ich habe so ein
Jahreskalender von jako-busch bekommen
da stehen immer jeden Monat so Sachen
wofür der Monat steht und ich habe das
Gefühl ich fühle zurzeit den März extrem
wie er sich anfühlen soll so vieles
richtet sich irgendwie neu aus oder so
steht da drin und ich habe das Gefühl
ich
überdenke zurzeit alles
oh mein Gott
jetzt fällt mir erst auf ich gucke ganze
meine Hände an und denke mir ja Mist die
werden ja ganz dunkel ja weil ich keine
Handschuhe angezogen habe was ist denn
mit mir los so ist das wenn man langsam
30 wird Leute da kommen dann die ersten
oh es gibt sonnig oh es hat euch
wahrscheinlich schon die ganze Zeit
getriggert wenn ihr das Video euch dazu
angeguckt habt na ja aber dann war es
schön
leise wenigstens wenn man diesen lauten
Handschuhen
färbt es sich schon anders ja ich glaube
das waren eigentlich meine Gedanken dazu
schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare was
ihr zu dem Thema denkt ich habe es beim
letzten mal echt genossen eure Meinung
zu lesen und das hat sich echt angefühlt
wie so ein Austausch auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht antworte oder nicht so viel
antworte ich lese wirklich eigentlich
alles und ja bin mega happy dass euch
die letzte Folge so gut gefallen hat das
Ausspülen muss ich euch jetzt nicht
zeigen meine Haare sehen danach ganz
genauso aus wie jetzt bin ich ehrlich
lasst euch nicht verunsichert werden
jetzt halten zusammen denn sie ist ihr
seid auch willkommen aber seit ein
bisschen näher dazu okay bis denn
tschüss